in the show that I'm just winding up now
uh the work of the devil which which
contained two major revelations in the
second half one of which the most famous
one and what it's sort of about it was
the discovery that I was donor conceived
and um I learned through a DNA test that
I was actually conceived in a clinic in
central London run by a woman called
Mary Barton and her husband bertol
Wiesner and the husband bear talk
Wiesner was it turns out supplying the
vast majority of the sperm that was
getting women pregnant over the course
of about 22 years it's thought to a
father somewhere between 600 and a
thousand children so I have all these
half siblings the first time I went into
that room where they were all having
lunch at the first big Gathering there
were 27 of them in there and they were
the first Blood relatives I had been in
a room with
ever
I mean that's extraordinary isn't it at
the age of what 55 or something I think
the kind of the core philosophical
conundrum that you get to through
recognizing it and pondering on it is
there is no alternative it's not like I
could have been this or I could have I
would not exist
foreign
[Music]
I'm Francis Foster I'm Constantine and
this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with Fascinating
People our terrific guest today returns
to the show for the third time he's one
of our favorite comedians here in
Britain and has also become a very
prominent commentator as well Simon
Evans welcome back to the show thank you
very much I'm very excited to be doing
my third show I am looking forward to
wearing my badge we'll have to design a
badge I think there should be one or
maybe a tattoo or something yeah yeah oh
absolutely on your forehead it comes
with a free bank account cancellation oh
yeah I've been reading about those yeah
they're spreading out now aren't they
yeah just want to make it clear that we
were the first yeah I actually have my
bank account canceled in
1993. oh yeah
um before I'd even become a comedian let
alone a commentator
um just for not ever like having enough
money in my bank account you know what
we're just this is getting boring yeah
yeah that's a very
exactly it was like stop stop fooling
with us you know I was like I was I was
basically like broken up with I got a
Dear John Letter From NatWest so uh yeah
so I have you know I have that mottled
Sympathy for the current way yeah well
it's pretty extraordinary What's
Happening Now isn't it I mean
weaponizing Financial Services is kind
of I I mean people it's a sort of it's
the sort of thing that weird conspiracy
people on Twitter with weird avatars
used to sort of say in our cdbc and and
this and that and now it's happening it
does seem to be happening yeah I think
the first time I became aware of that
level of interference was during the The
Trackers uh Demos in Canada and that was
particularly disgusting because of
course people were trying to uh support
them through charitable donation and and
the um the platforms through which those
donations were collectible going sorry
we're not going to give back to the
truckers but here are some causes that
we're going to support instead I mean
that was a level of of course for you my
so that was was quite jaw-dropping I
mean almost comical but um yeah I mean
it is
I don't know individual cases obviously
yours you know it just seems appalling
other people there might be reasons who
knows you know obviously you don't want
to uh stick your your nose in too far
and find out what might be going on but
that level of control that level of of
chill you know every so often you think
with it with the with the the the the
general Trend that we've been talking
about obviously since trigonometry has
been around that kind of quiet
authoritarianism that's that you know
the the ability to to
um uh render certain narratives or
points of view inoperable non-viable uh
to move the Overton window you know we
keep thinking it's it's losing it's it's
momentum now it's petering out and then
something like that happens and you go
no actually it's it's moving into a new
and slightly more Sinister form and do
you feel that authoritarian Chill on
your shoulder Simon well I mean I don't
know that I
I I've always tried to keep it at arm's
length you know I host a show a couple
of weeks a couple of nights a week on GB
news and GB news some people would say
is it you know is um very much uh uh you
know chivalist for a certain kind of
tribe in the in the culture wars but I'm
not one of those people who kind of puts
that in my bio and goes here I am you
know and I don't have flags and emojis
in next time
I personally don't feel I've been closed
down personally you know and I I don't
think my bank account is under threat
but of course you never know which HR
departments have decided that you're not
going to be hosting their Awards this
year you never know uh which venues have
quietly thought no we'd probably rather
not have him touring it I don't think
anything like that has happened but of
course you know you you wouldn't
necessarily hear about it if they're
doing their job well those
authoritarians you you don't know until
you just sort of find yourself washed up
on some beach on some Uncharted Island
and uh and no longer booked and Simon
you've always been someone who had
something to say in addition to the
comedy that you did it's one of the
reasons I'm such a big fan of yours uh
but in with GB news and with more
writing that you now do for the
Publications uh you've kind of stepped
into a little bit more of a commentator
role as well more so than in the past I
think is that fair to say yeah I mean I
started writing for spite a couple of
years ago I think it'll be two years in
September um that initially started
really actually with the sort of couple
of comedian obituaries quite sad but my
good friend and the guy I'd worked with
Sean Locke died and um and they asked me
to write an obituary for him and and
then once you're sort of anchored to
them I write a fortnightly column for
spite
necessarily I suppose because that's the
kind of Engagement you know that this
sort of conversation that triggers
engagement you find yourself one week
reflecting on something that feels like
in the meat of the bat for me like uh
um I don't know I mean I am by Instinct
quite nostalgic quite uh reflective
quite
um quite mellow honestly you know and
occasionally be if becoming infuriated
if anything by triviality and so on but
um but you you do notice the engagement
absolutely skyrockets as soon as you
start talking about certain you know hot
button topics and so that eventually
happens you know well it's been five
minutes so let's talk about trans
as we all do yeah uh no but I what I was
going to ask you is it's actually
something I mean I don't even do stand
up anymore something what do you make we
asked um uh Norm who who owns the comedy
seller in New York about comedians
commenting on things and he actually
thought was quite a good thing because
comedians offer a slightly different
perspective on things have you enjoyed
that do you do you enjoy that do you
think comedians should do that I mean my
take on on slightly edgier topics has
always been as I always I've been doing
it for 25 years I think straight away I
was started to do that is to tease
people and tantalize them with the
prospect that I'm about to say something
appalling or you know something that
will get me cancer and then just pull
back from the edge and that's what I
think of as edgy comedy the point of the
air juice that you're going to go you
know you get the vertigo but you
shouldn't actually be shoving people
into the chasm you know and um and I
think I've done that for a while I mean
I used to do a joke like 20 I say 25
years ago I think about um saying
um I have uh developed a painful
condition
um went to see the doctor about it
Indian chat
pause while they go oh my God he's going
to say seven children about Indian
doctors uh Indian chat well they call it
Indian chap it's just nappy rationally
that kind of joke I think
um it's interesting even just over the
course of my career you know you will
get people now who will recoil more
firmly and and be harder to tease back
out again yes but I mean just on the
trans thing I I in the show that I'm
just winding up now uh the work of the
devil which which contained two major
revelations in the second half one of
which the most famous one and what it's
sort of about it was the discovery that
I was donor conceived and um I learned
through DNA tests that I was actually
conceived in the clinic in central
London run by one called Mary Barton and
her husband Beto Wiesner and the husband
bertolviesner was it turns out supplying
the vast majority of the sperm that was
getting women pregnant over the course
of about 22 years this has become there
are other cases of this coming out
there's been one come out this week in
fact
um but uh at the time and for several
years this was a standalone it's thought
to a father somewhere between 600 and a
thousand children so I have all these
half siblings
so I use that to discuss
um to give me the right I suppose to
discuss the work of the devil being kind
of technological stroke sociological
developments and Innovations which are
messing with nature are we are we sure
that it's fine that not only can two gay
men get married and but they can have a
child they can have a baby what methods
are they using for this to happen
Express a certain amount of
old-fashioned shock and horror about
that in the first half then revealing
the second half that exactly those
methods were were used to bring my
existence about if we hadn't been
willing to I mean in in the view of the
church at the time it was they regarded
it as a brain wave of Beelzebub so I am
literally the work of the devil but the
other one which I find as interesting as
well was I had very low testosterone
and I did a blood test and found that
that was causing me a certain amount of
mental fog and actually sort of
something quite close to depression
really just like feeling miserable and
and unmotivated and so on and I now take
regular testosterone injections which is
not that unusual of course in
middle-aged men but at the level of
testosterone that I had prior to those
injections I was eligible to compete in
the women
at the Olympic Games and so that that
again I think gives me a right or at
least an opportunity to um tease a
little bit about you know let's see how
how do we feel about you know and then I
mean recently the the the the substance
I use is called Sustanon I think it
comes from Australia for some reason
and um and and there was a a sort of a
bottleneck in Supply I think actually
just caused by government interference
and wanting to see documentation or
something I went on Twitter to find out
if other people were getting these
problems and all the other tweets were
were trans
trans men who were using sustain on
relying on Sustanon to complete there or
to continue their transition you know so
I really genuinely am in in that you
know I am in that cohort by some
standard it's your lived experience
Simon exactly yeah yeah and so just just
as a brief segue what was it like before
you had tea replacement and after tea
replacement
well in the I don't know how long it had
been like really scraping along the
bottom because it was it was quite bad
by the time I had the blood test but the
sense beforehand that I was most aware
of was a sort of a loss of motivation a
loss of decision-making ability there's
some quite interesting experiments been
down where
um a human brains have lost the part of
I can never remember which region it is
but the region that um is emotional and
um and some people think oh that will
turn you into Spock right you'll just
make clear decisions without having
emotions Cloud your thought processes
and in reality the opposite happens
without emotions you have no idea what
to do you have no template you know you
have no um Rights and Wrongs it was a
bit like that I found it very hard to um
to determine even in what order I should
put on my socks and trousers in the
morning you know I mean I could be
hesitating over that kind of thing you
know and if four or five different
objects were sitting on my desk
requiring attention I might spend the
whole afternoon I know you literally
became a woman too
there is a sort of um I mean there is a
an old man thing to that as well I had
the testosterone levels Associated
traditionally with 80 year old men but I
mean funny enough I'd already spoken
about it there's a I think it was a BBC
show the big question hosted by Nikki
Campbell which had had an episode about
um masculinity and crisis you know and
that had been my thing talking about
mainly because I'd read about it rather
than realizing I was subject to it that
um
men at all ages now on average have
roughly half the testosterone that we
used to have and I mean I suppose the
question is well is that necessarily a
bad thing is that going to diminish the
amount of Pub fights and you know and
brutalized marriages and so on or is it
actually uh why we might all just be you
know productivity is down and we don't
quite know what we want to do next there
is a kind of feeling like the whole
country is is seized by that same lack
of Forward Motion at the moment I don't
know I don't know how much that Maps out
but afterwards to answer your question I
felt pretty good almost straight away a
lot of the clouds cleared and I had a
surge of activity and
um like everything you know nothing
lasts you know the feeling of becoming
better is the greatest feeling you know
convalescence you can't carry on forever
and man I didn't keep pumping it up and
like Pumping Iron you know but um
although I will say actually funnily
enough I mean I do go to the gym and I
had noticed that it was beginning to
become very difficult to improve in the
gym and I can now occasionally if I like
set my mind to see some results there as
well so that is kind of important but
yeah I mean everything comes back a
little bit and obviously the thing
people will think about is libido which
yeah to some extent I mean it doesn't
restore you to your twenties but um you
have some sort of sense of being a an
active player in the world I suppose
again yeah and I saw your show that
showed that you are wrapping up now I
saw an earlier version of it uh before
the pandemic actually
it's a brilliant show really really
fascinating uh and uh part of it is of
course your character on stage this is
another dimension that you didn't
mention your character on stage has
always been of this slightly somewhat
snooty English gentleman yeah it turns
out you're not you're not you're not
English at all not English at all no my
mother's side is actually in a way
almost obviously the father's genes are
pure Ashkenazi my mother's side is like
seems to be Celtic induced European and
there's a bit of North Africa in there
as well which is really mysterious but
um they my parents who are both still
alive and not particularly interested in
pursuing that and finding out why that
might be but yeah I think I think to
some extent it's I think when you start
out in stand-up comedy you um try on a
few different Persona and um I'm quite
interested I read a book recently or
listened to it as I always do now uh
Camille pallia's sexual Persona and um
and thinking about Persona which like as
in masks in performance and so on they
have to be quite
like oversimplified and and specific and
direct and consistent in order to create
drama within you know what is otherwise
just the you know the mud the mess of
everyday life and I think when you start
out as a stand-up you try on a few some
people I did anyway you know to see
which one the audience bought basically
you know and I I remember the first few
gigs I did I was trying to present
myself as a bit of a kind of I don't
know Joe Strummer type character I
thought of myself as a bit of a rock and
roller you know in my late 20s early 30s
I was a bit bit chaotic anarchic you
know and uh bit of an outsider and a
rebel and I remember audiences
a bit more like a lounge lizard you know
there was a character Rob Newman used to
do a Newman and the deal that was a sort
of a Jarvis I think he was called who
was sort of slimy and unreliable you
know and Superior and callus and and I
found that they were yeah no we could
see that yeah so you'll work on that but
I think over the course of a stand-up
career unnecessarily you will if you
allow yourself to you will evolve and
it's important you do because otherwise
you start just repeating yourself I
think the first 10 years or so I was
like that then I think I moved into a um
I moved into a slightly different
Persona when I had kids and became
admired in Domesticity and then I became
you know uh your classic sitcom dad you
know beleaguered you know and you know a
bit more tony Hancock and I felt much
more comfortable in that terrain ever
since actually I think
I don't know what it was I think when
you were when you were a cuckoo in the
nest and you don't know why
you look around for a Persona that might
enable you to critique the expectations
of your own family and upbringing and so
on and I didn't feel comfortable
entirely in that upbringing and I
thought well maybe that's one way I
could do it
but
um
funnily enough on the way up here for
instance I was listening to a wonderful
book
um
by Don Patterson I don't know if you
know him he's a Scottish poet and he's
written A Memoir of of growing up in a
pretty poor family in Dundee Dundee area
and um it's vastly more recognizable to
me that background weirdly than any of
the stuff I sort of purported to be a
part of you know when I was a stand-up
he's he's talking about you know uh
um Street games and and and and
playground nonsense and uh
um you know uh collecting coal that had
fallen off the back of the cold truck
that's how poor they were he was sent
out after the cold now we weren't quite
that poor but I was a lot closer to that
than the sort of thing I pretended to be
and after a while that kind of um that
kind of mask just gets uncomfortable and
you want to throw it off but
I mean yeah having children was a
natural break in that I think
um
I think I'm making a conscious one now
having done the work of the devil it
feels like that was a culmination like
everything I'd done for the previous 25
years could suddenly be seen in a new
and clearer light oh that's what was
going on do you know what I mean there's
an interesting book called I think the
structure of scientific revolutions
Thomas that came out I think in the
60s but he encroached the idea of the
paradigm shift
and he says in if I've understood it
correctly which is you know far from
certain he says uh what happens we tend
to think of science as as uh proceeding
gradually in a linear fashion he says No
in fact you have a set of theories which
purport to describe and explain a
certain phenomena let's say
um you know the the organization of the
solar system and
um and and in order to make the
observable facts fit that theory more
and more pressure builds you know more
and more implausible workarounds or uh
uh exemptions from the apparent rules
and if you see the maps of the of the
solar system and the orbits that the
planets were supposed to be uh pursuing
in order to obey the ptolemaic universe
if anyone's noticed but if you put the
sun in the middle it all gets a lot
simpler and I'm just saying you know
well I think that happens in our own
lives as well to some extent you know
you you think to yourself
I I know I'm I don't know I know I'm
this I know I'm that I know I'm the
other and everything has to be crammed
in there and something you know I'm just
saying if you turned out to be half
Jewish
and and your father had not been you
know that that would explain quite a lot
of it wouldn't it and you kind of go oh
yeah so it would and the whole like heap
of all the material I've been doing for
the previous 25 years is suddenly you
know thrown into a new light by that and
having done that that being the sort of
nature of that show
um I feel like I almost just want to
clear it all away you know what I mean
and start again in some kind of Peter
Brook you know experimental theater
empty empty space kind of uh right what
should we talk about now yeah well
that's exciting for you creatively but I
was gonna actually ask you something
that I'm thinking about a lot obviously
I had my son about 13 months ago and
it's something I think we need to talk
more about in the public space and I I'm
I'm trying to do that which is
fatherhood and Parenthood more generally
uh what was it like for you and what
kind of impact did it have on you
becoming a father and uh did it spur you
on did it did you look at the world in a
new light or was it more of a burden in
terms of your career and creativity and
so on uh well a number of things
happened all well it's not all of which
were directly just having a child
um my wife experienced quite bad
postnatal depression and I think that
was probably a bigger issue in terms of
maintaining my own sanity and balance at
the time
um she was determined to carry on
working and I think that was possibly
one of the reasons why she was
experiencing so much pain and discomfort
because um I think for women I mean
you're absolutely right fatherhood but
also parent and I think motherhood even
more so I think you know but both
parents but especially women are I'm
paraphrasing my own wife I wouldn't dare
to say it just off my own bat but she
says they're fed alive they're told a
lie that they can have it all that you
can have kids and carry on enjoying your
same career and you see and it just
isn't true and I'm not saying she's the
first one or I'm the first one to
acknowledge this obviously you know
people have written books about it
um it's funny how careful you have to be
about saying that though yeah because it
is something I mean you're paraphrasing
your wife I will now paraphrase my wife
and you can speak to lots of women who
will you can paraphrase afterwards who
will all tell you exactly that which is
you know you have been sold a bit of a
lie it changes the way you look at your
life your career everything and those
things cease to be as important
absolutely and um I mean funny enough I
was listening yesterday and I'm going to
start throwing around my literary
references too fast but um essays of
montane who's like contemporary slightly
earlier than Shakespeare so this is 500
years ago so people have been thinking
about this but he talks about the senses
about how we may have there may be other
conceivable senses of which we're not
aware and if you he has a blind friend
who just doesn't understand what
um
what he's missing and uses terms he had
a godsend and he says oh what a handsome
boy as he picks him up and holds him he
cannot see him in the word handsome to
him who knows what that means but he has
heard it and he uses it I think
Parenthood is a bit like that and
especially for mothers until you have a
child you don't know what it is that
gets switched on inside you it's not
like wanting to get home to see like a
TV drama that you've been following and
being annoyed when your train is delayed
because you can't get home it's not like
it's not it's a tug you haven't felt
before it's a hook that's placed into
the center of your being on a tightened
court that you you cannot Escape
and and even now and Matilda our
daughter is uh 19 and on her Gap year
and sends in WhatsApp messages and
videos of her tearing through Northern
Thailand on mopeds without a helmet on
and I see them and go what's she like
and I can see it is having the same
effect that Kate would have if she saw
her pram starting to roll down the hill
you know it's it's it just never goes
you know so as a father I think to some
extent you are then coping with that you
know and the the domestic environment
becomes more
um yeah more complex than you you might
have thought you know and also if I'm
honest I suppose we had a few well there
were a few conversations we perhaps
should have had before we had the
children which which might have at least
allowed us to uh navigate beforehand and
know exactly where we were going like
what Simon well for instance
um it turned out my wife was
particularly Keen that may be privately
educated which has been extraordinary
and is one of the reasons she wanted to
carry on working so that that could
happen now I'm not sure that would have
been a priority for me but certainly
it's one of those things I think if
you're going to have kids it's I mean I
don't know if this is this is tricky
because on the one hand I would say yes
as an individual if you're going to have
kids you will probably benefit from
having a lot of serious conversations
beforehand before you even get married
really about you know if we're getting
married this isn't just a question of
like expressing devotion and love for
one another we are what we're about to
do make setting up a business look
trivial you know having children by
comparison with getting a mortgage or
something together is you know it's it's
an enormous commitment and you have a
great line about it don't you something
about how you're around we've set up a
small business together this is going
well why don't we see why don't we get a
troop of baboons to run the posters yeah
yeah it's disruptive and also you know
you want to make sure your values are
roughly aligned people talk about value
alignment now in terms of AI but you
know we find it hard enough in marriages
we think the marriage will go fine
so part of me wants to say that to
individuals but of course as a society
we're already dipping well below
replacement level fertility and anything
you say that puts people off
I don't know I mean it's a it's a tricky
conundrum because the truth is of course
I I mean I've I've started to form the
view over the last few years that a sort
of realization that the traditional
purpose of religion as much as anything
else was to enforce fertility
you know to stop people just having fun
you know to take their responsibility
for for planting and and uh and
harvesting seriously and um it's it's
terribly tempting to just keep putting
it off and if I say things like oh you
need to make sure you both agree exactly
on you know well maybe you should just
like let nature take its course I don't
know I do not know my own father
um born in 1930 I think he discovered
quite recently going back through his
own uh Parish records I say my father
might social father or whatever my dad
um that he was born at the end of March
1930 his parents have been married three
months previously so that tells its own
story as well you know um he probably
wouldn't exist if they'd had a
discussion about value alignment you
know me neither so who knows who knows
but um yeah you can't you can't minimize
it and and it is disruptive and and
interesting I know that some people have
said I know some men say you know you
have a child and you go right I will go
out and provide well if you can do that
that's great but on the other hand of
course it is quite again the domestic
environment does suppress testosterone I
mean that's proven
um if you allow yourself to become
enveloped in its warm embrace you know
the whole point is to stop you playing
around for instance you know the more
testosterone you have the more likely
you are to be to try and be unfaithful
and um so nature is generally encouraged
that to go down and that then of course
might diminish your inclination to go
out hunting quite as often you know but
um
yeah it changes you and it's not always
easy to anticipate how it will do so you
know and and although you hear a lot of
men going I absolutely it's all about
that it's all about my wife it's all
about the little you know you do also
notice a lot of men start taking on
later nights at the office and so on I
mean there was a I don't want to call
him an absolutely you know an absolute
hypocrite but um I can't remember his
name Ben something I think a sort of
Outdoorsman who makes TV documentaries
about
um you know going down paddling down the
Amazon and that sort of thing and he did
one of those interviews like lifestyle
interviewing the Sunday magazine you
know saying I always carry with me the
the you know the Polaroid of the of the
my wife and and daughter because that's
who I'm doing it for and I'm like mate
you're away for three months shooting a
documentary on the Amazon you don't get
to present as the devoted father I'm
sorry you are making you are absent you
know and uh there are other ways you
could have earned a living but you want
to do something exciting I don't blame
you but you know let's not pretend that
you are doing it for them you know
hey KK Do You Believe In Spring cleaning
yes but only when my wife does it in
Russian men who clean up executed for
not being real men which is correct well
for those men who are living in the 21st
century manscape has an incredible offer
for you manscaped are the global leaders
immense below the waist grooming and
have forever changed the grooming game
with their amazing performance package
4.0 inside this care bundle you'll find
their lawnmower 4.0 trimmer weed whacker
ear and nose hair trimmer crop preserver
ball deodorant crop Revival toner
performance boxer brief and a travel bag
to hold your goodies this Elite trimmer
is designed to trim hair on loose skin
although your huevos might look like a
couple of Boris Johnson's treat them
with respect and benefit from their
proprietary skin safe technology
complete your grooming game this spring
with the new refined cologne signature
scent by manscaped this stuff is legit
and we'll have you smelling like royalty
the good kind not prince Andrew get 20
off and free shipping with the code
trigger 20. at manscape.com that's 20
trigger 20 at manscape.com it's time to
throw out all your old hygiene habits
and upgrade your life
we've been talking a lot actually what's
very interesting about this into
interview is about identity and when you
receive that news about who your
biological father was what did that do
to your identity your identity as a son
to your father but also who you are did
it make you literally question every
single thing about you
well I wouldn't say every single thing
but it certainly changed my relationship
my realization for instance my
relationship with my father Yes and I
realized and I still do think that I've
spent quite a lot of my adult life kind
of Defending his views to an extent that
I might not have done if I didn't
actually find them so puzzling
or his way of being seeing it at a
slight remove you know and always
thinking I admired for instance the fact
that he he made a very plain decision
early in life I think to accept that he
had to sell eight hours of his Waking
Life every day to a firm uh and do
something in which he would not take a
huge amount of constructive
satisfaction but then he had his hobbies
in the evening and he always got all of
his satisfaction from life out of Model
making gardening carpentry winemaking
and all sorts of weird incredible Rich
Homie be life there's had no real
interest and I always one of the reasons
as a stand-up I don't really like it
when when Compares stand on the stage
and say to the bloke in the front row
what's your name and what do you do
because they're being they're being
asked for their job title and that isn't
who people are you know and yet I've
gone down completely the opposite route
I have virtually no hobbies to speak of
and I get all my creative satisfaction
from the work I do as a career
and so I I suppose I always had him a
sort of one remove in a way and I felt
almost fiercely defensive of him I mean
I didn't vote for brexit didn't want
brexit I wasn't like a fierce remainder
but um but when the hostility emerged
two people who had voted for brexit and
my father had voted for brexit you know
that aroused in me a kind of like uh uh
a Red Mist you know level of defensive
you know you know don't you dare call my
father an idiot bigger racist whatever
I'm not sure
I would one
woman who was actually one's biological
father I don't know but I feel like I
was protecting a man who I had a
slightly unresolved relationship with in
that respect and I think I feel I see it
slightly more differently now but in
terms of identity and this is It's
extraordinarily but potentially toxic
but I am in no doubt I think
um I've always had like massively
disproportionately more Jewish friends
than than you know you would expect from
representation my best friend at school
as I say in the show was Ross Cohen who
was the best man my best man at my
wedding and I now know was the only
other Jewish boy in the class you know I
don't know that that could have been
coincidence it seems like an old one to
me so yes I do think there is you know
just a smidging of Jewish identity that
comes from God knows how uh some sort of
you know Juno type expression in in
personality but um
suppose it's funny enough one of the
people I used to have regular
conversations with about is their
identity you know one of the reasons I
think I've wanted to take the DNA test
which I don't explore that much on stage
but I think I had become aware that
everyone I think this was about two
thousand
sixteen everyone seemed to be
aligning more and more with their racial
or ethnic identity that was becoming a
big thing and it had
um underscored a lot of uh yeah tribal
behavior on Twitter and so on and I
thought I don't even really know what my
ethnic identity is Evans is a well
surname but I don't we don't have any
kind of sense of being Welsh there's a
sort of
um you know there's a there's my parents
have done a bit of the old-fashioned
version of ancestry and that disappeared
into the mud of you know of uh
beneficiary subsistence farming and I
thought maybe if I discover you know
some Viking or Mongolian or some kind of
warrior horde from 2000 years ago that
gives you some sense of of being
anchored in the past
other people seem to draw some sort of
sustenance from and not always
necessarily a bad thing you know
um I think a lot of us I think a lot I
think I say us a lot of those of us who
felt we were just white British in a
vague sense felt a certain amount of
Envy for those who could say I am I
don't know Palestinian British or I am
uh Iranian British or whatever they have
some ethnicity with a with a with a
story to it that has had a little kind
of inflames the imagination a little bit
I didn't expect to find what I did of
course and uh having done so in a way I
find that I can close that book now and
I don't actually rely on it but I do
recognize that it it probably informs me
a little bit more than uh
than I had previously recognized because
so many of my traits are traditional
Jewish traits you know and has it
changed your mind about the whole
nurture and nature debate are there
things that you look at and you just go
now that you've got this information you
go well actually this this isn't my
lived experience for one of a better
word Simon I think my funny enough my
view of the nature Nursery debate has
been affirmed by I don't think I was
that rocked because I genuinely do I've
been firmly in the nature side for quite
some time
um I'd done a bit of reading anyway I
found Robert plowman's work on it very
interesting you know that seems to me
fairly unambiguous I think that there's
you know I understand why people want to
believe
um that uh they can nurture their
children and my father of course took on
the responsibility of doing so on the
understanding that he would have some
impact on who I am and I don't want to
say sorry Dad you know but I don't know
I don't think there's any shame in
feeling that it's all a lot of it is
baked in there seems to be to me most of
the um most of the literature now most
of the the the science seems to confirm
that something between 50 and 75 percent
of what you might call personality
traits or whatever are pretty much baked
in through
um genetics albeit with the ability it's
not predictably baked in based on the
two people who are mating you can have
two completely different children in
fact if anything the thing the first
thing that will teach you that nurture
is is an illusion is your second child
you know because as soon as you try and
apply exactly the same parenting
techniques and they just you know what
the hell happened there
um but even then yeah so there's some
kind of there's a lot of noise even as
your body tries to read the blueprint
and you're going to say what sorry where
are we supposed to put the you know and
and Chinese Whispers is as good a
description as anything for how you know
the um the the cracks that the light
gets in or the swerve you know as
lucretius has it but the um but the
other part is even more weird is the
non-shared environment they say there is
you know there are
um environmental effects but they have
no idea what it is the shared
environment is the family or your
friends whatever the non-shared
environment is essentially the the dark
matter as far as I can tell of of um
personality
and nobody knows what it is but I was
pretty much there with that already you
know I was already quite convinced of
that in a way that was why I wanted to
sort of have a name and a tag to put on
my identity to know what it was you know
what was what was emerging what was
expressing itself
and I think if we got past the idea that
consequently if he just put enough money
into education or whatever we can raise
a universally you know High achieving
um cohort of young people who are
currently being let down by Nursery or
whatever if we could just get past that
nonsense that fiction that that fantasy
it would just take so much of the
pressure off parents who might be like
concerned that they are failing in some
way as soon as their child turns out to
struggle with math you know it's like
so much of it is is I'm afraid you know
which is not to say that they don't need
some sort of support structures but
parenting is much more fun if you go to
be honest it doesn't really matter if we
spend the weekend going over their
homework or like just like rolling
around like Gorillas in the Mist
that is not going to have a long-term
effect on their educational prospects so
I feel that is
that would be like the gospel if we
could get it out there that again that
funny enough goes back again because my
wife is genetically predetermined
that you need to spend the weekend going
over that homework so you know but it's
also it must have been impressed on you
the genetics and the roles genetics
plays in all of our Lives even though we
don't want to admit it when you met
brothers and sisters I I know one of
your brothers that must have been a real
light bulb moment which one do you know
I know David tabazelle oh okay that's
interesting yeah I mean and we were born
quite close to each other as well I have
brothers and sisters stretching
backwards mostly back to 1945 my oldest
brother is 79 now sounds like you're
from the Nation of Islam
[Music]
David and I have worked together I mean
we are obviously close and we think we
may have been from the same batch as we
put it because he was certainly freezing
batters because he was getting old and
had Parkinson's by the time we were born
but um
yeah um yeah I mean it certainly did we
don't all I mean we're half brothers and
sisters so there's the opportunity for a
lot to be uh you know messed with but um
as a cohort we are yeah there are
certain traits you know now I could then
say are they from uh from visner
or are they like Ashkenazi traits and I
personally think they're pretty much
obviously Ashkenazi traits you know
pretty much everyone is very verbal
you know they all have there's an awful
lot of us as I put it in the show who
have leveraged a degree of verbal
fluency to avoid doing any hard work
and I feel
I feel certainly you know but then
Ashkenazi it's weird because I know
there's been a uh you know a long
history of arguing is it a faith is it a
a an ethnicity you know uh Judaism
um there's a famous line from one of my
absolute all-time Heroes Alan Curran uh
reading about uh the Jewish Chronicle I
think it was congratulating him on
becoming the first it wasn't the first
Jewish editor a punch but something like
that something he'd achieved and he went
what nonsense I haven't been Jewish for
years no he's obviously tongue-in-cheek
but that you know and at times of course
that has inflamed I mean that's kind of
you know that's the uh part of the whole
past the road to auspect stuff you know
is it just a religion or whatever
but you know the the data is in now it's
an it's an ethnicity and the most
definitely identifiable and unmistakable
ethnicity
um probably of any in Europe
you know the the particular Heartland of
um of the Ashkenazi Jews from uh
Germany Poland round there or whatever
and um to the extent that David
um finds through a perfectly you know
not not alarmingly but he is connected
to Wiesner twice he was father by him
but it was also
a tiny bit incestuous
his Union you know his his mother was
slightly related to uh daviesner which
is again not that unusual you know
um so if you want to have like a um I
don't know a a a a test case a natural
laboratory for testing these things then
the Ashkenazi have already presented you
with it to a very large extent I don't
are you are you fully asking I'm a
quarter quarter okay yeah and what what
are the three quarters uh so I'm half
Eastern European which would be a mix of
Russian Ukrainian and a quarter
um I mean we would say Greek but it's
probably more like ottoman Greek right
okay you know from from that part of the
yeah the Black Sea Coast I'd imagine
yeah yeah yeah well that's quite a
common but again the verbal thing I
think yeah
hard work I I was curious uh to to touch
on uh your relationship with your father
and I'm curious about you talk about it
in the show a little bit the impact that
had because here you are you suddenly
realize this person you've called your
father and thought of as your father and
treated as your father isn't your
biological father and he was you know
what maybe this will be me revealing
publicly how weird my parents were but
they always asked me what how I would
feel if I'd found out I was adopted now
in my case there's zero chance of that
because they had me when my mother had
been 18 for four days right so I don't
think they were in the adoption market
so to speak at all it was a complete
accident and again wouldn't have
happened if people had thought about
childbirth as carefully as you suggest
they do no um but it is an interesting
question I think and the question that
most people would actually think about
in some way you know what happens if you
realize that your parents or one of your
parents isn't actually your parent yeah
it's interesting that your parents would
ask you that I mean mine obviously
steered me away
I imagine certainly you know I mean I
remember you did used to think when I
was I remember very specifically having
these thoughts I think maybe age or nine
but I can picture myself in bed thinking
I'd just don't think he's my dad and yet
I cannot imagine a scenario that would
that would explain that because I knew I
wasn't adopted because my mother had
gone into a lot of detail about exactly
how painful and touch and go labor had
been you know I was in I think an
incubator for a couple of days and she
was desperately like sad that she wasn't
allowed to hold me and cuddle me and she
talks about that quite often and we get
Misty eye talking about it you know and
you wouldn't make that up you know just
to kind of give plausible
and so I knew she wouldn't have had an
affair I mean there was like zero chance
of that or anything weird like that and
obviously it never occurred to me that
such a transgressive scenario as as
artificial insemination would have been
used well why did you think that your
dad is not your dad is it just because
you're so different it's a really good
question I think at that age I can't
have been thinking it logically so I
think it must have been visceral and I
think what it might have been I said I
sometimes think it might have been
um like pheromones or something like
that I used to be quite affectionate I
would sit on his lap sometimes when I
was little and watched TV you know and I
would I was very fond of him and he was
a you know lovely Big Bear to hug
but I kind of felt differently about his
smell and being than I did about my
mothers you know with whom I would kind
of absolutely you know
um Nestle up to like like a pup in a
basket you know whereas with him it was
more like an uncle and I do remember
also I had another Uncle we're a quite a
small family my mother's an only child
as well and my father has one half
sister his mother died very sadly before
he was one and um and his father
remarried and uh and they had Margaret
and so Margaret is supposed to be
related to me and it turns out isn't as
well my cousins her two daughters were
supposed to be related to me aren't
related to me and then there was Fred
her husband who was not supposed to be
related to me and I always instinctively
felt a really strong bond with Fred
because I because I think I'd I'd
mapping this out now but I think it was
because
I didn't sense that I that there was
something I was supposed to feel or
sense that I wasn't getting so I relaxed
about it do you know what I mean he was
just a man who was married into our
family and so I kind of instinctly oh
we're we're like you you and I we're the
same you know but where that came from I
mean I just don't know
um and I don't want any of this I mean
my dad was really a great dad you know
he was a totally like a mensch
but you know it was weird I know my um
my one of my best friends Danny uh
Solomon who um I was at University with
and his dad uh Harry Solomon you really
do stick with you a lot don't you yeah
yeah so he used to come up to you go
down to Southampton location and take us
out for dinner and Harry took us out for
dinner me and Danny at one time and um
had this weird feeling like um this is
weird this feels like a dad you know
like uh this is how I you know I I'm
getting a little kind of bat signal like
a of uh
this could be and then when I met
Jonathan Wiesner who again is 78 I think
um who is the natural born son of Berto
ricner and Mary Barton and was the kind
of Rosetta Stone through which we all
went over his
he's quite like sir Harry Solomon and
quite like again I mean he's my brother
but but I actually feel like he's my
father so you you genuinely feel like
kinship with people to whom you're
biologically related to you perhaps
hadn't met before in yeah that is so
interesting man I mean the first time I
went into that room where they were all
having lunch the first big Gathering I
was you know it was they were the first
there were 27 of them in there and they
were the first Blood relatives I had
been in a room with
ever wow basically putting aside my own
mother you know blood relatives of any
thing approaching my own tear you know
my own generation
I mean that's extraordinary isn't it at
the age of what 55 or something you know
it reminds me of something I was talking
to a friend of mine because obviously my
wife and I we left having children quite
late yeah so we'll probably you know who
knows how many will be able to have I'd
happily you know have a lot unlikely
biologically to happen and I was talking
to a friend of mine who has adopted
children
and he without being overt about it was
kind of he was saying it's it's not as
rosy a thing as you think now I'm not
saying that's always the case for people
but it's interesting that there is that
physic whatever physical or whatever it
is it's so fascinating to me but we we
went on this side track a little bit and
I asked you about the relationship with
your father and what changed for you
when you found out that actually you're
not by and it sounds like partly things
clicked into place for you yeah I mean I
suppose yes there's always a point you
you lose something I suppose
um we have moved into perhaps a slightly
more pragmatic recognition of the truth
and I know he felt hugely relieved when
um I went up and told my parents you
know and some people said you shouldn't
do that because it might be of a shock
to them they might have managed to
suppress that information apparently
there were some fathers who you always
attended the the clinic together but
there were some of them that were told
that their sperm will be mingled with
the donor sperm and it might just
encourage it Forward give it the full
propulsion when it got there it might be
there spermen got the woman pregnant you
know so they might be all kinds of
things that they've allowed themselves
to believe
but when I told them there was huge
relief definitely and
um and I think he had always just felt
you know that um it was a fairly trivial
thing you know and I certainly don't
want to like kind of like Shake him by
the repels and go no it's not trivial
you know this is this is life itself you
know but my view has to be that you know
I have to recognize the truth of it and
there is a powerful Bond there but that
is absolutely of course not to see the
thing you I think the kind of the core
philosophical conundrum that you get to
through recognizing it and pondering on
it is there is no alternative it's not
like I could have been this or I could
have I would not exist they may have had
a child by some other means they might
have adopted or something but I wouldn't
exist there is only one set of
circumstances in which I exist and
that's it you know so there's no point
at all in thinking I wish you this or I
wish you that you know whatever or
recognizing it just I wouldn't be you
know
but I I do think
um it's it's probably relatively minor
compared to the fact that you know my
father was
89 when he when we closed that he's now
93 their elderly you know and they are
the relationship with your parents
changes at that point anyway you know
you realize it's on you now to be the
parent you know to an extent and um you
know I don't think I don't think the DNA
connection is that important in terms of
the responsibility I have towards them
or whatever at that point you know we're
we're far past the point of which you
you know you have the kind of Rebel
Without a Cause kind of tear stained row
on the landing you know about
you shouldn't
the only way to do it you know but
that's what we can't do that's that's
gone so you know what I'm getting from
this interview Simon is uh what a
wonderful man your father is oh he is a
great man yeah he is I can't talk about
it for long on stage really before the
old lower lip starts yeah he is because
I think apart from anything else he's
like an absolute template for how you
make the best of what you have you know
which wasn't that much he had such a
blow
um to lose his mother he was like 10
months old I think tuberculosis nobody
knows really he has no memory of her at
all and uh he's he was farmed out into
foster care basically an extended family
because in those days you know a man
working man couldn't look after a child
on his own and then they came then they
came back and then this the and he was
given Margaret and uh and they are still
incredibly close but then the second
wife died again as I say it started to
look a bit suspicious now but he managed
the third time he was raised by his
stepmother well he was 14 and I think
when um when his father remarried the
second time to Ivy who I knew as my
Grand but she wasn't related to anyone
they had no children together people
would just like picked off left right
and centered you know what I mean like
the 1930s and 40s even without the war
she was a war Widow but most of it was
pre-penestinian that was the big deal I
think I still think people don't
recognize hell yeah you know how much of
the world changed when penicillin became
available that just you know people just
used to die all the time before their
fifth birthday you know it was
extraordinary so it emerges out of that
he's yanked out of school at the age of
14 by still living at that point with
with foster parents who were just tired
of of feeding a child who wasn't
contributing so they pulled him out of
school and made him go to work you know
he was a bright man he could have had I
would have definitely a a degree of some
sort and might have had a different life
but you know no grudges made his way as
I say created his own reality you know
that I could talk for an hour just about
his Hobbies you know and about how rich
he made his life at home and you wrote a
beautiful thread I think on Father's Day
perhaps last year about and his hobbies
and so on was it his was it Father's day
was it birthday but it was his birthday
yeah it's there yeah Aviation being the
big one he's so I've never met anyone
who knows as much about my about
anything as my father knows about
Aviation and not just I mean he'll spot
you know a mosquito 2 000 pesos or even
by by the specific wine it makes he made
over a thousand 172 Scale Models never
never moved out into a different
um scale
he's like that's his religion you know
that would be like uh like converting
but um yeah he made an apostasy it
sounds like exactly yeah he made over 40
specific different versions of the de
Havilland mosquito that was his like and
they are now in the mosquito Museum
and then but yeah I mean just like um I
don't know I feel like a different and
because I'm not like him I suppose I
sort of see him as a yeah almost as a
sort of
a figure I've read about in books or
something you know and um
I do have that uh yeah like that kind of
I'm slightly annoy of how anyone can be
that that patient and committed to a
certain
way of life without I suppose seeking
the affirmation that I've done you know
in my work and that sort of thing he has
just different needs and so it's I'm
very very grateful to have known him in
that respect you know but it is a a just
a slightly different recognition because
of that difference Simon I think Justice
having mentioned him earlier the first
poem I encountered a Don pasum was a
poem called the elliptical stylus which
is a fierce like like unbelievably
Fierce defense of his father in a
particular very like tiny uh scenario
and that was the connection I made with
him it's uh it's and he is I'm sure his
biological father but that is a a thing
that I find yeah is a very moving like
when you dwell on it even for a moment
you you get overwhelmed
hey Constantine do you like being
healthy of course in my country would
judge Men's Health by his ability to
wrestle bear in London I have since
found out this has very different
meaning we've all had a knight that's
got out of hand
[Applause]
we will speak no more of this the secret
will be buried with my unsuspectful well
if you want to stay healthy and not feel
like you need to be buried with
Constantine's ancestors then you need to
try ag1 ag1 is simple and easy way to
get all nutrients you need each serving
contains 75 high quality vitamins
minerals and Whole Foods sourced
ingredients one scoop and you feel like
real men we used it on our America Tour
where we were constantly on the Move
living out of a bag and working every
day ag1 meant we felt great look great
and we avoided getting sick one scoop a
day meant we knew we had all the
vitamins and minerals needed for the day
we heard hugely successful trip it is
very economical and I felt strong enough
to wrestle America which we all know is
grotosely weak compared to Great Russian
Bear if you're looking for a simpler and
cost effective supplement routine ag1 is
giving you a free one-year supply of
vitamin D and five free travel packs
with your first purchase go to drink
ag1.com
trigonometry if you're looking for a
simpler effective investment for your
health try eg1 and get five free agu1
travel packs and a free one-year supply
of vitamin D with your first purchase go
to drink ag1.com trigonometry that's
drink ag1.com
trigonometry check it out yes check it
out and become real men like me
it's it there are different generation I
remember you brought up the mosquito so
my grandfather was born in the 1920s my
British grandfather very very bright
very intelligent man went to school in
the north of England had to leave school
because it was the 1930s he was from a
working class background he emerged into
a Great Depression
in the northwest of England so he would
go and try and get work he would go to
Liverpool to Liverpool docks there'd be
hundreds of men who would go to the
gates of Liverpool docks a foreman would
come out and would pick you you the rest
of UF off just as this time that he
started to make his way the World War II
started he then he became a joiner and
he was working on the mosquito he was
and he was a master Joiner in the
factories in the north of England wow he
worked on that plane he worked on that
plane and then what happened is
obviously he was a very intelligent man
a very learning man self-taught man he
would read the newspapers he saw what
was happening with his Hitler in second
in the second book during the second
world war and he was omitted he didn't
have to go and fight because he was a
vital part of the war effort because he
was making the mosquito plane as a
master Joiner but he felt so compelled
to go and fight because he thought what
was happening in Europe was so egregious
that he gave up that job and relative
safety said goodbye to his family joined
the war effort then he fought in Italy
fought all the way down and then fought
in the Battle of El Alamein as a Desert
Rat wow and then after the end of the
war he was asked by his commanding
officer he said Foster you are a
magnificent Soldier you should stay and
we you should stay on and be part of the
army
and he actually said no because he
didn't see himself as a man of war that
was a principle for him and then he
returned to his family and raised a
family
I think that generation were different
the way they saw things the way their
sense of Duty iron maybe it's me
being nostalgic on projecting but
I think we've lost something I don't
think that generation I think we've lost
something of that generation that sense
of Duty that sense of there is something
more important than me when we live in
the age of the self
I mean yeah well I absolutely agree and
it's a sort of it's a huge conversation
in itself I I think there are certain
things I wrote a piece when when the
when the queen died last year
um just saying that I found it almost
baffling that people didn't that some
people could express bemusement at the
sense of loss other people felt you know
I I mean she'd been there my entire life
there aren't many people that had been
famous let alone you know as a symbol of
of nationhood or whatever for my entire
life but more it was a sort of stirring
of a of like what had one time been or
throughout most of human history you
know the most Primal emotion there is
you know your your your commitment your
your part of the tribe you know your
your your sense of of belonging to
something and being able to you know the
imaginative sympathy to be able to
invest in individual with a with a with
with that sort of symbolic importance
and regardless of scandals that come and
go or or personal failings not very few
of which she of course really had anyway
but um
I think it's a similar thing you know
the the ability to identify and almost
submerge yourself in something is
something that I still have a stirring
of but I don't know whether it will be
enough to sort of sign up to war if I've
been younger but but is gradually being
being lost and diminished as we
as we move as you say it's a kind of era
of individualism and um and and in some
respects you know liberal democracy has
has encouraged that and um and and you
know you've had plenty of guests on the
show who have who've um flagged the
dangers of collectivism under whatever
uh Banner it might fly I mean there will
be some people who would say that for
this very same reason that people like
your grandfather are less inclined you
don't exist now who would who would take
it on as a duty to sign up that's the
same reason that we don't see so many
wars we don't you know other nations
find it difficult to to master the um
support for their nationalistic
expansions or whatever so why why
Putin's activities in Ukraine apart from
anything that seems so jarring now such
such an extraordinary sort of abrupt
collision with all the values we had
assumed had just kind of like washed out
across the whole surface of the Earth
you know but also the age of self is an
individual choice you get to make that
decision every day do you commit
yourself to something Beyond yourself or
are you only worried about yourself are
you only thinking about you or are you
actually trying to whether it's your
family whether it's some other thing
that you're attempting to serve I mean I
certainly know that for me the most
fulfilling things tend to be things that
are outside of me yeah and so we all get
to make that choice do you want to live
on the edge of the self or not every
single day and we have plenty of
opportunity not to do that if we choose
not to well that's a good I mean I'm
glad you feel that way
um but some might say that it's so The
Temptations the
you know just the the artifacts the the
um the means through which to express
the individual uh in yourself are so
readily available and so instantly
addictive for one of the more
technically appropriate term you know
and Incredibly unsatisfying yeah yeah
absolutely they're incredibly
unsatisfying and once you realize that
then you've got to stop going on about
the age of self and start acting in a
way that serves you and other people
around you and is fulfilling and I you
know the reason I'm saying this that I
was just in the US at a conference which
is full of young people who who are
they're sort of on the conservative side
of the spectrum but they are interested
in environmental issues and climate
change and whatever they're all in their
20s uh 20 to 25 half of them are married
already most of them are about to have
children and they're working on things
Beyond them I just think we you know
we've got to realize we have the power
to change reality if we choose it you
know for ourselves no one's making us
spend our time on Instagram no one it's
interesting isn't it that
um I mean all of the studies I remember
it came out sort of 15 20 years ago the
the sort of positive psychology movement
Martin Seligman and so on and there were
a lot of books about that and I think um
Jonathan hikes but the happiness
hypothesis which is a terrible title for
an amazing book
um but uh
they emphasize that again and again and
again uh being part of something larger
than yourself from feeling yourself
emerged in a community that hopefully
you share goals together and of course
we all know the you know the collapse of
the church is a tragedy from that point
of view the superstitious element of it
was of almost no importance whatsoever I
mean I thought when I do my the show the
work of the devil part of the glory of
it for me is the ability to Express
gratitude at the end gratitude for the
sacrifices made that I could exist it's
such an amazing feeling when you Express
gratitude in front of a group of people
it's like a kind of I know people do a a
they say they feel better for it but I I
don't know whether they get that full I
don't know whether Church used to supply
that I'm sure but the ability to as you
say pursue a common goal with a large
number of people
is um is I'm it's great that you think
it is there but it it's not that easily
found out of course people will try and
encourage you to have a certain amount
of commitment to your company if you you
know you go into work but of course all
the different contractual obligations
and so on can undermine the the sense of
being voluntarily there it's it seems to
be a much more powerful effect on your
happiness and and satisfaction if if you
volunteer if you work for charity then
anything you get but a lot of people
even then will go watch a football match
on a Saturday afternoon and feel that
that's a communal Gathering but of
course it's totally passive they're not
working towards anything together
whereas if three or four of you I mean
my son's most satisfactory activity of
the memories is nearly 16 is the band
he's in you know and that has created a
he plays guitar he's got two or three
mates at any given moment in the band
and they are working together towards a
goal and it's obvious to me that that is
so much more satisfying for him than
playing his Xbox or whatever you know
hopefully that kind of Life Lesson will
stick even if he doesn't actually end up
headlining the pyramids I mean this is
why I enjoyed doing this much more than
I ever enjoyed doing stand-up yeah and
much more because there's that element
but I was very lucky I had a lesson that
I learned very early on uh I I used to
play basketball in the local park
there's a court there and I was doing
this kind of like personal development
course and they would get you to do
things that you feared or found
difficult or whatever scary and they
were like you need to you need to do a
project that's not about you but it's
about contributing to the your local
community so I organized a basketball
tournament right in this park right and
what I learned was the way people
treated me
changed like that
when you become of value to other people
yeah the your relationships with other
people change dramatically because uh
they see you in a completely different
light so for me it was a very practical
in your face experience of uh what
contributing to others actually does for
you so even in a very selfish way yeah
it's something that I learned very early
on anyway we've gone off the track Simon
put a bow on this for us a philosophical
bow if you like you you know discovering
what you discovered and doing the show
you just mentioned giving gratitude what
have you learned from all of this that
you you that would be worth sharing
other than what we already talked about
of course well you know it's funny when
you were talking and this I will this
I'm not avoiding the answer but just
going back to your basketball thing I
think it like if I had a single
um light switch moment in my whole life
light bulb or whatever it was when I
first started doing improv or improv I
think we then called it which was in
about 99 24.
um I hadn't really intended to I was
trying to make it as a journalist in a
newspaper asked me to review or like
write a piece about the sudden surge of
popularity because we had uh Whose Line
Is It Anyway on that's all and um
and I mean I could write a book about
what improv taught me other people have
tried to do that but you really do have
to experience it for yourself but the
the kind of taking a deep breath and and
jumping into an improv scene having no
idea where it's going to go trusting
other people to support you it's like
they you do those trust exercises where
you fall backwards and other people
catch you but in an improv scene you're
all falling backwards and catching at
the same time it's a constant like
emerging thing and it totally woke me up
to both those things the the uh the
satisfaction that can come from creating
something in real time with other people
nobody's trying to be a leader actually
in that situation so it's not quite the
same but you are providing value and you
are provided you are reassuring with
trust and also you're taking a huge risk
with vulnerability because if you do a
scene in real time you know there's a
chance you'll say something that people
this is the fear that people have will I
say something that makes people realize
I don't know something that I've been
trying to conceal and protect for all
this time
and over the course of a couple of
months of doing improv with these people
you might reveal yourself much more on
stage than you do you know off and there
are all kinds of exercises to get that
out of you and then also about letting
go I I've been left in like the most
helpless gills I suppose essentially
ever in my life they used to do a thing
called three-headed expert where three
improv players line up side by side you
can even like link arms and uh and
somebody like yourself asked them a
question and they're an expert on it so
you say um so Professor uh Wagglebottom
uh I believe you're an expert on the
Australian octopus yes that is correct I
have been studying the octopus for you
and and you just do it one word at a
time
but it teaches you that you're not in
control so you have an idea of where you
think this is going and then they go
somewhere completely different with it
and the realization that I mean it's
almost like the confabulation thing in
the split brain potion you know you're
laughing because you have no control
over what you just said
and and so the reason I mention that is
because fast forward to work of the
devil the thing I learned is that every
single time you take the risk
of exposing yourself the vulnerability
that's that's what creates the moment
that's memorable every time and the
first time you do it you might do it
quite clumsily and you can sense they're
supportive but they're not really
laughing but but once you then kind of
furnish it as well and do it with some
degree of
skill and competence it is so rewarding
it's like
you have to just constantly be tearing
off the carapace you have to be
constantly breaking the ice on the
surface because otherwise you as a
performer will find tricks to avoid
exposing yourself just like an
eight-year-old child will find tricks to
avoid exposing itself at school and and
the job you have is to constantly be
smashing those off ripping them off and
showing your software underbelly as
often as you can and that's what I've
learned and it's been you know a long
time coming I guess but it's um and now
I'm addicted to it now I have to like
hunt around what else can I expose this
as long as this might be of course the
downfall yeah as long as it's
metaphorical
soft white underbelly but stop there if
you don't mind yeah indeed but Simon as
always an absolute pleasure to interview
the last question we always ask our
guest is what's the one thing we're not
talking about that we really should be
well it's so interesting that question
because of course if you spend your days
on Twitter as I do or indeed watching
trigonometry podcasts it does feel like
everybody is talking about all these
things you know
um but out there in the real world I'm
going to take a massive sort of left
turn after everything I've been talking
now and I do think there is something
different about the AI threat
that the World At Large is not talking
about very much and the reason is I just
become aware recently I think you may
have spoken to some of them the chapter
I never remember names who um withdrew
himself from the Google projects and has
been saying we need to be very careful
you know maybe a moratorium and so on
well we all know there's not going to be
a moratorium on on AI research because
if it was enforced in Silicon Valley or
across America or the west or whatever
then all that would happen is our
enemies would would get the gain but
I've never seen people before
flagging up danger ahead in their field
of which they are an expert
where they are not asking for more
funding not asking that we invest more
in this not asking that this be raised
up in the agenda in government
programming and so on but literally just
going
I've got a horrible feeling we've opened
up a wormhole into a space through which
a torrent of demons might be about to
rush and I really think we should maybe
just like slow down here I I cannot
think of all I'm not I'm not a climate
change skeptic but you you can't help
but notice that all the people who who
are sounding that alarm are demanding
more funds are demanding more more be
done of of the kind of things that they
would like to see be done anyway they
they they're almost always have an
agenda for uh redistribution of
resources and so on that they would have
been quite keen on even if there weren't
this kind of climate but the AI thing
seems to be like very different and um I
think it's one of those things that kind
of you know you see a front and Page
newspaper it will have a picture of the
tennis from Wimbledon and
um the the latest you know uh spending
cuts in in the National Health Service
and just down the bottom it says AI
expert warns more than 50 risk of world
ending
you know existential threat from the
thing he's been working on for the last
30 years and you kind of go these
stories are not the same you know
so anyway I don't know what the solution
to that is it's obvious
it's obvious on my capabilities but I do
worry that a lot of young people feel
demoralized by you know
um the uh the threats made to now quite
significant you know previously
aspirational jobs not like just driving
trucks or uh or or saying to checkouts
by automation I I don't we need to
disentangle them and um and identify
what what might be uh that these the
experts are genuinely worried about and
engage with it well Eric Weinstein who
was sitting in that chair very not long
ago uh his argument is we need a new
economic model and I think that may end
up
may end up be one of the the potential
Solutions when you've got robots making
everything effective yeah
um it may it may actually open Humanity
to a world of very good possibilities
too we just but every transition in
history has been accompanied by a lot of
breakages well I think it was my my old
colleague on Radio 4 Tim Halford who
said that um you know if you take the
black Brock's approach then to some
extent there's very little difference
between traditional Automation and
um the shifting of factors to the third
world or the developing world or
whatever or just across the border in
America you know in the sense that jobs
just disappeared and were being done
somewhere else by something else in that
case you know poorly paid
um workers who knew no better than to uh
to accept that deal
and that has broadly speaking yes been a
good thing worldwide you know just not
for people in the Rust Belt or whatever
but uh I don't know it feels different
this time I think so yes a new economic
model where obviously you tax the people
who own the robots but you know the
capacity I mean it's always an arms race
isn't it the tax code you know between
the uh the attempt to claw some of that
back for the general good and um the
private sector accountants generally win
so I'm not sure you know what we do
about that from that point of view I
just wish I could see I mean as I say
I'm not pro I wasn't pro-brexit but the
one thing I thought was uh you know a
good argument for it was the sort of
agenda that Dominic Cummings had to be
honest that he wanted to see a change in
the way that Westminster was populated
in the way the cabinet was people by
people who had expertise in something
other than winning constituency votes
and and this is something we're still
struggling with you know there are just
too many people in in government who
don't have the kind of technical Mouse
to understand what they're looking at so
I think it's very obviously what went
wrong with the pandemic as well you know
the um you look at something I mean it's
not his fault but how the hell did we
end up going into that with somebody
like Matt Hancock in charge you know
I mean it's just it's just not good
enough you know it's not a question of
his morality or is uh it's like you know
uh rates mates or whatever it's it's
just not just not got the cognitive
Firepower but it's very difficult for
people who do have to find themselves in
cabinet through the traditional means of
creating a very little incentive to do
so yeah but anyway Simon this is the
most British ending too it's not good
enough yeah
follow us on locals where we're going to
ask Simon your questions and of course
make sure you go and find Simon online
follow him at the Simon Evans on Twitter
correct and of course you are going to
be doing an Edinburgh show uh a new one
which will then go out as a tour as well
so uh that's called have we met have we
met it's all about memory it's about
memory although The more I've written it
the more I realize there are all sorts
of interesting uh meanings to that
phrase not least of course relating to
my brothers and sisters
Simon uh and you guys head on over to
locals we'll see you there
I've been subject
[Music]
s